jeden tag öffnen wir unsere geschäfte
trotz aller gefahren
von kharkiv bis nach levi von kiew bis
odessa haben bomben und saarland
vernichtet
der metro markt von mario pohl granat
einschläge überall
[Musik]
alle länder der welt sind vereint um die
ukraine zu unterstützen alle länder der
welt um russland zu stoppen doch die
deutsche metro ag macht weiter geschäfte
in russland und die ukrainische
mitarbeiter wenden sich an ihren
arbeitgeber
wir flehen euch an brecht die
beziehungen zu russland ab
nur wenige kilometer von den kämpfen
entfernt versuchen sie in einer kiel war
metro filiale die versorgung der
bevölkerung aufrechtzuerhalten
trotz blockierter lieferwege und
luftangriffen irgendwie eine aufgabe
unter extrembedingungen erzählt uns der
marktleiter der nächste luftschutzkeller
für die kunden ist auf der anderen
straßenseite dort bringen sie sie bei
fliegeralarm zu unserer mitarbeiter
haben wir auf dem gelände der metro
einen kleinen bunker wo sie den alarm
abwarten können
gab es situationen in denen sie sich
dort verstecken mussten wir hören
ständig die sirenen beim luftalarm
evakuieren dann aber bisher ist zum
glück nichts passiert
700 kilometer nordöstlich die geschäfte
laufen die filialen der moskauer metro
sind weiter geöffnet wie überall in
russland den sanktionen zum trotz sind
die regale hier gut gefüllt
während viele westliche konzerne ihre
tätigkeiten in russland eingestellt
haben möchte die metro vom geschäft
nicht lassen fast als gäbe es den krieg
in der ukraine nicht
der konzern hat viel zu verlieren
93 märkte von metro cash & carry
erzielten zuletzt ordentlich gewinn rund
200 millionen euro in 2020 das freut
nicht nur die manager sondern auch die
staatskasse von wladimir putin etwa 22
millionen euro steuern zahlte die metro
im jahr 2020 an russland
2000 kilometer westlich vom kreml liegt
die firmenzentrale der metro ag in
düsseldorf
vor wenigen tagen proteste der
ukrainischen community symbolisch
beerdigen sie ein opfer des krieges und
die moral der metro womöglich gleich mit
dass man im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert immer noch versuchte mitten
im krieg in europa dann ja auch noch
geschäfte mit dem aggressor inland zu
machen das hätte glauben können daran
hätte ich nie geglaubt das ist für uns
ein klares zeichen dass das profit und
die marshall die metro-gruppe viel
bedeutender ist als die menschen leben
in der ukraine verantwortlich für die
entscheidung der metro ceo dr steffen
gröbel seit einem jahr leitet er das
unternehmen jahreseinkommen über sechs
millionen euro wir würden gerne mit
greubel persönlich sprechen doch dafür
hat er keine zeit er lässt über seinen
sprecher ausrichten man könne verstehen
dass die entscheidungen der metro auch
kritisch bewertet werden kann zitat
dennoch sieht der vorstand auch eine
verantwortung für die 10.000
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter von
metro russland und ihre familien sowie
für die versorgung mit lebensmitteln
21 jahre lang war er als top manager für
die metro ag tätig dr jörn klöckner
verantwortete die rechtsangelegenheiten
weltweit auch in russland das die
versorgung der russischen bevölkerung
ohne metro märkte gefährdet sei glaubt
er nicht es gibt einen komfort verlust
für die kunden von cash & carry wenn die
märkte geschlossen sind aber genau das
will man ja erreichen man will ja ein
mit einem boykott unannehmlichkeiten
erzielen es wäre sicherlich gut für
metro wenn sie in irgendeiner weise
einen klaren punkt setzen würde ein
klares statement setzen würde dass sie
auch durch aktionen und nicht nur durch
pressemitteilungen gegen diesen krieg
eintritt doch statt klarer aktion gegen
den krieg finden wir auf der website von
metro russland ausschreibung für das
geschäft für straßenbau und erdarbeiten
für dekorationen oder den neubau von
gasleitungen
die metro-tochter in russland investiert
weiter und schweigt zum krieg
stattdessen auf der website ganz oben
attraktive angebote zum angrillen im
frühling wenn metro der auffassung ist
dass der russische markt so wichtig ist
dass man darauf nicht verzichten kann
dann würde ich zumindest erwarten dass
man ein ein teilschritt geht dass man
zumindest
einzelne märkte ab schaltet das angebot
reduziert investitionen auf eis lässt
eben genau das macht was die anderen
unternehmen als benchmark ja auch
vorschlagen und auch umsetzen trotz
geöffneter geschäfte in russland betont
die metro oberste priorität hätten jetzt
die 3400 mitarbeiter in der ukraine auch
dort betreibt das unternehmen 26 märkte
fünf davon liegen im kriegsgebiet
mussten den betrieb einstellen
[Musik]
dieses foto zeigt die mitarbeiter in
mario pohl vor kriegsbeginn 100
angestellte hatte das unternehmen hier
mehr als die hälfte von ihnen soll noch
in der zerstörten stadt sein kontakt
gibt es nur noch zu wenigen
satellitenbilder zeigen die metro am
stadtrand das gelände von
bombenanschlägen zerfurcht
inzwischen das berichten russische
medien hätten prorussischen kräfte den
markt übernommen diese fotos sollen
zeigen wie sie die filialen nutzen um
menschen zu registrieren und
lebensmittel zu verschenken für die
mitarbeiter hier kann die metro nichts
mehr tun außer die gehälter zahlen der
konzern schreibt
als metro helfen wird den kolleginnen
und kollegen in der ukraine die
unterstützung durch metro wird von
unseren ukrainischen kolleginnen und
kollegen geschätzt
lmf dawidenko ist die chefin der metro
ukraine sie hat eine botschaft an die
deutschen konzernlenker
[Musik]
ich kann nicht länger schweigen wenn
tausende ukraine jeden tag sterben im
namen aller ukraine und meines teams
fordere ich sie auf stoppen sie ihr
geschäft in russland
ihre mitarbeiter kämpfen um ihr land und
ihr überleben
technik chef konstantin tauschte den
metro kittel gegen tarnanzug und
maschinengewehr sales managerin darina
hat sich den truppen als köchin
angeschlossen logistiker dimitrow und
sein bruder maxim von der
gemüseabteilung jetzt soldaten und olga
aus dem einkauf mit maschinengewehr
[Musik]